[موسيقى]
يتساءل بعض الأشخاص عن سبب
وجود متحف المستقبل ، الافتراض هو
أن المتحف مخصص للماضي
ولكن بالنسبة
لنا الماضي والمستقبل والحاضر
موجودان جميعًا في سلسلة متصلة
ونحن جميعًا جزء من  نفس الشيء
، مساحة مخصصة لتشجيع الناس على
التفكير في ذلك والشعور بأن جزءًا من ذلك
لا يقل أهمية عن أي متحف ،
اسمي برينان ماكجيتريك ، أنا
المدير الإبداعي لمتحف
المستقبل ،
ما أردنا القيام به في جميع
بيئاتنا المستقبلية هو  جعل الناس على
دراية بالتحديات أو الاحتمالات
الموجودة في الوقت الحاضر وإظهار كيف يمكن
باستخدام الطاقة المناسبة أو السياسات الصحيحة
تطويرهم إلى شيء
في المستقبل ،
فإن العوالم التي قد تواجهها
ليست تنبؤات بل هي تحديات
تعمل بجد لتحقيق ذلك  نشعر
بأننا مختلفين عن متحف نموذجي ، فنحن لا نقوم بأي من
تقنيات صنع المتحف التقليدية
المتمثلة في وجود ملصقات تحتوي على نصوص تنظيمية
تخبرك بشكل أساسي بما يحدث
لأن إحساسنا  ng هو هذا النوع من
إطالة الأشخاص خارج
منطقة الراحة الخاصة بهم ويساعد في دفع تفكيرهم
حول المستقبل بطريقة يمكن أن تكون
مفيدة حقًا.
حاول مسحه
ونعتقد أن متحف المستقبل
يشجع الناس على فهم
أنه شيء  نحن نصنع المستقبل
ليس شيئًا يصل فقط
بشكل سلبي ، إنه شيء
نخلقه بنشاط من خلال أفكارنا
وأعمالنا
لدينا بيئات
تشبه مجموعات الأفلام تقريبًا التي تحاول توضيح
أنك في مكان مستقبلي
نريده حقًا  الأشخاص الذين يشعرون بأنهم
منقولون ،
فأنت مقيم أو مستكشف
لهذا المستقبل والتجارب المختلفة
التي لديك هي تجارب خاصة بك ، لذا فإن
متحف المستقبل هو
امتداد لمدينته دبي ، إنه
مكان يمكنك من خلاله زيارة الكثير من المناطق
حيث تركز دبي بشكل مكثف في
الوقت الحالي على
استدامة الفضاء والعافية
مثل جميع المعارض ، تكون المحطة الفضائية
تفاعلية وتسمح
للناس باستكشاف سلبياتها  خيمة ، لكنهم
يريدون المكتبة هي واحدة من
الميزات البارزة في المتحف ، إنها في
الأساس قبو من الشفرة الجينية ،
أحد الأشياء التي أردنا القيام
بها بالمكتبة هو جعل الناس يدركون أن
العديد من هذه الأنواع معرضة
للانقراض عندما
امسحها ضوئيًا ، تضيء الجرة باللون الأحمر وستكتشف
أنها قد انقرضت بالفعل
أحد الأشياء التي كنا
ملتزمين بها للغاية ونحن لا نزال
ملتزمين بالتأكد من أننا لم ننشئ
متحفًا مخصصًا للأشخاص الذين هم فقط
مهتمًا بالخيال العلمي أو مهتمًا فقط
بالتكنولوجيا ، حاولنا التأكد من أنه
عندما تزور هذه الأماكن حتى لو كان
نوع مظهرها غير مألوف ، فإن
ما يحدث هناك في نوع
القيم والطموحات الكامنة وراءها
يمكن التعرف عليها تمامًا.
نقدم أنفسنا كمتوقعين أو
كأشخاص يتنبأون بالمستقبل
، نوضح أن ما تواجهه
هو رؤى للمستقبل ،
إنها احتمالات ما هو
متحف المستقبل.  تحاول أن تفعل ذلك هو تمكين
الناس من الشعور بأن المستقبل
لهم وأنهم يمكن أن يكون لهم دور فيه
[موسيقى]